salut bon dimanche à vous je le dit
doucement parce qu'en général le
dimanche je pense que vous regardez
cette vidéo dans votre lit donc je veux
pas vous brusque et non plus et le jour
de l'explication de la semaine
aujourd'hui je vous explique quelque
chose qui va vous permettre de bluffer
quelqu'un soit aujourd'hui soit dans la
semaine
la semaine dernière je vous ai appris à
bluffer quelqu'un l'aide d'une playlist
je vous en reparle à la fin de la vidéo
j'ai une très très bonne annonce à vous
faire à propos de ça mais d'abord le
tour du jour vous pouvez le faire en
même temps que moi dans ces cas là
prenez un papier un crayon et sinon vous
pouvez juste regarder poursuivre la
démonstration et regarder les
explications à la fin je vous ai
concocté trois petites bulles il ya une
boule rouge une boule jaune une boule
verte et à l'intérieur j'ai mis des
chiffres j'ai mis trois chiffres dans
chaque bulle trois chiffres de manière
aléatoire vous allez devoir composer
aléatoirement trois nombres qui
utilisent tous ces chiffres de la
manière suivante vous prenez un chiffre
de la bulle verte de la bulle jaune et
un de la bulle rouge
ça vous fait un premier nom pour le 2ème
nombre vous faites la même chose vous
reprenez un chiffre dans la bulle verte
1 dans les buts shawn heins dans la
bulle rouge mais attention un chiffre
qui a déjà été utilisée dans l'une des
bulles ne peut pas être repris et donc
votre troisième nombre vous le
construisez avec le dernier chiffre de
la ville verte le dernier chiffre de la
bulle john est le dernier chiffre de la
bulle rouge vous additionnez ces trois
nombres ensemble avec votre calculatrice
si vous voulez vous pouvez faire pause
le temps de le faire et surtout calculer
la somme soit vous appuyez sur égal et
vous avez un nombre à vous maintenant un
nombre aléatoire qui a été composé de la
manière dont vous avez piocher
complètement aléatoirement les chiffres
dans les banques sachez évidemment que
ce résultat je le connais déjà je sais
déjà que vous de l'autre côté de la
caméra vous avez comme sommes mille 9009
qui n'est pas du tout un nombre
aléatoire puisqu'il s'agit au moment où
je vous parle de mon nombre d'abonnés
sur instagram et si vous voulez me
rajouter sur instagram ces familles en
quarts mais pas trop le plus simple on
va passer maintenant à la partie
explication juste avant que j'aborde
cette partie si jamais ça n'a pas marché
sur vous c'est vous avez fait une erreur
tout simplement je ne veux pas lire dans
les commentaires ah ça marche pas là sur
moi ça fonctionne c'est purement
mathématique ça ne peut pas rater
attention c'est pas un tour en mode défi
c'est un tour que je vous explique à
vous pour leur faire d'autres personnes
de la partie précédente c'est surtout la
démonstration pour que vous puissiez
voir comment ça va mais dans toutes les
vidéos d'explication où je parle de
maths et que vous me dites ça n'a pas
marché sur moi dans 100% des cas c'est
juste que vous avez fait une erreur
mathématique voilà c'est dit
l'explication est très simple si on
réfléchit tous les chiffres qui adore la
première
ils seront les centaines quoi qu'il
arrive tous les chiffres de l'adp
deuxième bull seront les dizaines quoi
qu'il arrive
tous les chiffres de la troisième bull
seront les unités quoi qu'il arrive donc
peu importe dans quel ordre
on va construire les nombres du moment
que les centaines restent à leur place
les dizaines à leur place et les unités
à leur place également on aura toujours
le même résultat la même somme quoi
qu'il arrive pour le faire à quelqu'un
vous pouvez construire votre propre
nombre à vous dans ces cas là vous
commencez par créer une addition et
ensuite vous allez faire vos bulles en
fonction il peut même y avoir quatre
bulles 5 'bulles' bull le mieux c'est de
lui donner un petit papier à chaque fois
qu'ils utilisent un chiffre dans une
bulle il le bar comme ça vous êtes
certains qui ne reprendra pas une
deuxième fois et puis vous derrière le
papier vous marquez le résultat en gros
comme ça quand la personne a fini son
addition elle a juste à retourner la
feuille est avéré que vous aviez prédit
le résultat à l'avancé vous met dans les
commentaires de la vidéo un pdf
téléchargeable que je vous ai préparé si
vous l'imprimé que vous le plier en deux
vous aurez d'un côté les trois bulles et
de l'autre côté la prédiction comme ça
vous n'avez plus qu'à imprimer à plier à
faire le tour il est pas beau le
dimanche je vous l'annoncé en début de
la vidéo je reviens rapidement sur le
tour de dimanche dernier il s'avère que
j'ai eu une discussion avec fabien
arcolle cas un grand magicien grands
créatifs et il m'a fait part du fait
qu'il avait un tour avec une version
similaire qui prenait ce concept-là
quand je dis similaire on parle bien de
la base du concept parce que lui aller
mais beaucoup plus loin alors ce qui est
assez drôle c'est que j'ai retrouvé son
idée sur la connaître au départ mais ça
c'est quelque chose qui peut arriver en
fait qu'on réfléchisse à un même sujet
sauf que moi je vous ai livré sa d'une
version basique en fait elle que ça
m'est venue que lui il a réellement
travaillé dessus durant des années il en
a créé un tour qui est hyper complexe où
tout est malin en fait je suis même pas
sûr que vous trouviez évident le lien
entre les deux est la plus le billet
dans un livre qui s'appelle douceur
mental donc ces douceurs mental de
fabien arcolle si vous voulez aller
beaucoup plus loin dans cet effet c'est
lui qui a pensé à utiliser cette idée là
historiquement il en a développé un truc
de ouf merci fabien de m'avoir fait
découvrir cette version là c'est juste
formidable et 2 fabien pour le prix d'un
du coup n'hésitez pas à me laisser un
petit commentaire si vous faites le tour
à quelqu'un pour me raconter comment ça
s'est passé
n'hésitez pas non plus à laisser un
petit pouce en l'air parce que ça fait
plaisir c'est encourager ça c'est cool
si vous êtes nouveau sur cette chaîne
bienvenue pensez à vous abonner en
cliquant là haut est passé à un
excellent dimanche rendez vous demain à
17 heures pour le prochain mortal blog
ciao